[Musique]
ma mère qui est canadienne du sang du
canada de manitoba elle avait tout
toujours de la dinde et mon père est
anglais d'angleterre ils sont très bien
dans l'angleterre
c'est comme la folie furieuse à noël
c'est la dinde et moi c'est du côté de
ma mère parce que du côté de mon père
était polonais donc on mangeait peut on
mangeait pas de dead ce classique du
temps des fêtes se cuisine depuis
longtemps bien avant l'époque de
nous-mêmes ou une grand mère ce sont les
autochtones qui ont mangé laden en
premier parce que c'est un oiseau
d'amérique et il avait domestiqué autant
les aztèques que les iroquois rien il
avait domestiqué et quand christophe
colomb arrive en amérique il pense qu'il
est en aide alors comment ils surnomment
c'est oiseaux qu'ils voient pour la
première fois une pole d'inde
alors ça vient de là et c'est lui
cortese par la suite qu'ils vont
apporter c'est dead en europe donc en
espagne par la suite ça va se répandre
cette habitude d'en consommer en
angleterre et en france
mais c'est véritablement dans les années
oulala d'un devient l'oiseau par
excellence au centre de la table à noël
pour séduire tous ceux et celles qui
trouvent la dinde trop sèche différents
produits sont proposés sur le marché
heureusement pour le consommateur il ya
de plus en plus de choix
yola dingue de nature rappelons la
nature surgelés et il existe toute une
gamme de dingue qu'on dit à ses années à
6 années ça veut pas dire qu'on est
juste ajouter du sel et du poivre
ça veut dire que la dinde a été imprégné
par une technique d'injection d'une
saumur à base de scène deux faces faire
et d'autres assaisonnements le but de
cette opération lors c'est de faire en
sorte que la dame vaut mieux retenir son
jus durant la cuisson la teneur
naturelle en pro tm de la dame sait à
peu près 22 pour sable si vous regardez
les étiquettes des dance au mur et sans
être marque en dessous 16% 17% ou 18
pour sa prochaine de viande c'est
toujours mieux de choisir la dengue qui
a la plus haute teneur en protéines
parce qu'on veut pas payer pour avoir de
l'eau là d'un dépôt de tombes
et d'arroser en profondeur de margarine
d'huile de coco on injectait auparavant
des préparations à base de gras choses
qu'on ne voit plus aujourd'hui la dinde
préféré de faire et puis j y ai je
vraiment impressionné par là les
ingrédients c'est évidemment de la
dengue de l'eau du sel du sucre ça va
naturel et épices donc ça se rapproche
beaucoup d' une saumure maison alors je
pense qu enfin les producteurs les les
transformateurs sur tout et contre les
consommateurs qu'ils m'aident beaucoup
moins d'additifs le seul additifs que
j'ai remarqué c'est le phosphates de
sodium
outre la batture bao commercialisé par
exceldor olymel propose le flamingo
lorsqu'on choisit un dance au mur et on
ne fait rien de plus on met la dinde au
fond on n'a même pas besoin de la balle
jaune et où durant la cuisson ses
conseillers de tout simplement la mettre
au fond
un petit papier aluminium dessus et en
cinq six ans on enlève le papier
aluminium et le tour est joué
il est possible d'acheter également des
dattes fraîches et la nouvelle venue
cette année laden précuites emballé sous
vide permis tout ce choix
leslie préfère se murer el-menzah des
avec les saumures qu'on fait maison on
peut ajouter des ep soul on peut
contrôler un peu le sahara et même
aujourd'hui on donne des idées mais ça
aux gens aussi d'adopter cette somme ira
longo
s'il veut mais du sirop d'érable veut
dire qu'arsenal c'est un peu de garder
les proportions puis le timing du sud il
faut commencer avec laden qui est déjà
des gelées et laden qui est pas saumur
et d' avance de 8 ans de sel ok une
tasse de sucre pour cette l'hebdo
parfait ok ça c'est la base
alors ensuite on peut faire des folies
furieuse avec ça alors on va commencer
avec des oignons alors j'ai des 10 2
oignons coupés en quatre on n'a même pas
besoin d'enlever les peaux ensuite moi
je mets une orange
j'aime bien les oranje belles oranges
c'est bon avec le leap-x alors c'est ce
qu'on voit et ça fait nos membres
je vais vous avez alors je mets la
jemaye les litiges du persil et jeu mais
je mets la moitié dans la saumure ici
pour la dinde et jeu mais l'autre moitié
dans le fond pour dans la cuisson des
pains ensuite je m un morceau de
gingembre je dis c'est pas énorme c'est
comme on dit des doigts gingembre mais
quand même tranchée je prends les
feuilles de céleri pour les épices
leslie propose du thym des feuilles de
laurier un bâton de cannelle du poivre
en grains et de l'année ses toiles et
une fois tous les ingrédients mélangés
ne reste plus qu'à y déposer le dindon
et mouiller à hauteur après 24 à 48
heures on y près en fournit faut
absolument
un rack parce que sinon on veut pas que
laden touche le fond quelques légumes
des herbes une tasse d'eau composeront
la base de la future source
juste avant de le mettre au four on va
le badigeonner moitié beurre moitié de
l'huile d'olive et moi je le mets
partout et un peu de poivre à la fin
pour ce qui est du temps de cuisson on
peut se fier aux tableaux sur les
emballages
mais chaque four à ses caprices
peut-être que votre fort est mal ajustée
peut-être qu'il fonctionne à 25 degrés
de moins ou de plus que celle que vous
commandez ça dépend aussi de votre tee
soir les rôtissoires en aluminium
jetables peuvent ajouter jusqu'à deux
heures aux temps de cuisson
parce qu'ils réfléchissent la chaleur
même chose pour les rôtissoires ans
nationaux excusable si vous utilisez la
bonne vieille rôtissoire en métal
émaillé foncez c'est la cuisson la plus
rapide on se fie au thermomètre
on est sur internet et on doit cuire la
viande blanche contre la poitrine
jusqu'à 74 degrés celsius alors que la
viande brune donc l'intérieur de la
cuisse
on vise plutôt 82
[Musique]
pendant la cuisson de son dindon laisse
les confectionne une farce qu'elle fera
cuire à part de l'union du céleri et de
la sauge revenu dans l'huile de pain
coupé en cubes
puis elle ajoute du bouillon pour
humidifier le mélange ça c'est bon qui
colle un peu ensemble comme ça c'est bon
un peu de sel du poivre et surtout
plusieurs noix de beurre pour le rendre
plus cru si la cuisson 45 minutes à 3
175 degrés autrefois la farce
elle n'était qu'esthétique alors elle
s'est levée et servait à tenir la taille
de l'animal ou la volaille n'importe
quel volailles pour que pour que
l'animal ne s'affaisse pas et c'est
vraiment par la suite donc au xviie ou
xviiie qu'on commence à manger
cette farce là et on l'a prêtait avec
les aliments du pays
ils ont servi avec quoi avec des pommes
de terre avec des légumes
qu'est-ce qu'est ce qu'il y avait moi
c'est toujours la même chose alors c'est
toujours purée de pommes de terre
c'est toujours des choux de bruxelles
parce que sinon c'est la fin du monde
c'est toujours une purée de carottes
avec la rue tabaga ensemble c'est
toujours la sauce gamberge et des fois
les haricots verts
[Musique]